so good evening we have a lot to get
through and I need a sense of whether we
have a cork it does seem that the room
is pretty full so I'm gonna say we do so
welcome to this meeting
for the board of the Engine corporation
held here at jeaious conf us
I spoke into a few of you but for others
who I haven't met yet my name is Hayley
Dunn braver and I've been hired to
analyze the failures that occurred
during the incident at Easley Nublar so
I know this is currently a rough time
for many of you and that there is maybe
some uncertainty about the project
moving forward and that's why I'm here I
was hired to review the recent incident
and to catalog the points of failure and
to suggest some next steps for the
project so I'm going to talk to you
today there's gonna be four parts
alright
and first we're going to review the
events of the weekend so we can all be
working from the same set of facts
second I'm going to dive into the flaws
within our design workflow now this
isn't going to be about failures within
the code itself but it's more about our
process on our practice of software
engineering
third we're going to discuss engineering
ethics and look into how ethical
breaches compromise this project and
finally I'm going to cover the idea of
chaos engineering and I'm going to
suggest some steps that we could take to
build a more resilient Jurassic Park I
really want to be on the same page with
everyone with respect to the events of
the weekend so we're going to do a quick
review now so hands up can you tell me
if you've read the written account of
the failure at Jurassic Park alright I
see a few hands that's good what about
those who viewed the video footage okay
more that's good alright so that helps
as those who are familiar with both can
attest there are a number of
discrepancies between the two accounts
right and from my research it's clear to
me that the video footage provides the
most accurate account so that's what
we're going to go with
first let's meet our consultants dr.
grant is a paleontologist and he works
with his postdoc dr. Sadler who's a
paleobotanist dr. Ian Malcolm has a PhD
in mathematics and he's an expert in
something called chaos theory he details
this as the idea that systems are really
complex and that they're likely to
behave in unpredictable ways even when
small changes or flaws are introduced
relevant staff members include John
Hammond who's the creator of the park
Dennis Nedry who was the lead software
developer for Jurassic Park dr. Wu who's
the head scientist robert muldoon who
was our game warden John Arnold who was
our chief engineer and Donald Gennaro
who was our chief counsel all right so
now that we know the team let's discuss
the events after a construction worker
was killed in an accident
grant Sadler and Malcolm were brought to
the park to render their professional
opinions
Malcolm was aware of the nature of the
park from the beginning and was
consistently against the project he was
convinced that the park would never work
because of chaos theory
and we're going to discuss that more
later grant and Sadler were unaware of
the true nature of the park they thought
it was something more akin to a museum
but they were initially surprised and
delighted by the dinosaurs
while this visit was taking place Dennis
Nedry was on site to take care of
software bugs we've since learned that
he was unhappy with the terms of his
contract a while back he was approached
by a competitor who wanted to open a
similar park and wasn't above bribing
Nedry to steal some embryos to which
Nedry agreed during the park visits
there was a significant storm while some
of our people were on a tour of the park
and a number of systems went down some
the result of the storm and others
because Nedry had purposely brought them
down in order to execute his plan most
notably the electric fences went down
Nedry died while trying to get the
embryos to his handler and was not able
to resolve either the purposeful
software vulnerabilities that he had
included to execute his plan or the
multitude of software bugs that were
there anyway grant discovered that some
of the dinosaurs had been breeding even
though this was supposed to be
impossible because we had made sure that
all of the dinosaurs are female
geneticists dr. Wu Hughes frog DNA to
fill in the holes in the genetic code
and apparently certain species of frogs
can change sexes when in a single sex
environment in order to continue the
species or as Malcolm puts it life finds
a way while grant and others were
evading Raptors dr. Sadler with the help
of Muldoon and Arnold was able to
manually reboot the power and Hammonds
granddaughter was able to get the
computer up and running again because
she knows Unix
this success this success came at a high
cost because both Muldoon and Arnold's
were lost in the effort and they weren't
the only ones during this incident we
lost Nedry Muldoon Arnold and Gennaro
and we also lost the construction worker
previously there were also many many
close calls Cod we have a lot of hiring
to do check the website ok the remaining
team members with various injuries and
traumas were able to escape once the
storm had cleared and the t-rex and the
velociraptors were keeping each other
busy and this brings the relevant events
to a close alright so now that we're all
on the same page let's talk about
software engineering at Jurassic Park
John Hammond claims that he spared no
expense in the creation of this park but
this really isn't the case the resort is
luxurious and yes genetic engineering is
pricey but I've determined through my
research that we drop the ball in terms
of software and we're gonna explore some
of those pitfalls in this section I'm
gonna be nice to Nedry but I have harsh
words for him later
from the evidence I've gathered it's
it's even hard to believe this but it
was clear that Nedry did not know he was
writing software for a dinosaur park
instead I discovered that the
requirements he had been given included
vague instructions like write software
that will dispense food at pre-recorded
times write software to monitor a series
of electric fences write software to
visually scan the area and report back
Nedry eventually figured out what the
software was for and he had his
suspicions confirmed by our competitor
but he should have been in from the
first and if we didn't trust him to be
in from the first then we should have
hired someone else even if that would
have cost more
Hammond was trying to be competitive by
keeping his plans under wraps but he was
setting himself up for failure by not
giving his software development team
critical information in addition to not
telling Nedry what software's for an
unrealistic timeline wasn't forced there
a scope creep insufficient budgeting for
instance Nedry tried to get more money
to fix problems but was threatened with
retaliation and when the scope creeps
and the budget is blown how much testing
do you think really happens and what
critical features do you think are
deemed good enough now don't get me
wrong all code has bugs and problems
everyone you know no one's perfect and
everyone has their share of flaws and a
project can always be improved but not
perfect code is a far cry from poorly
designed poorly documented untested code
running in a production environment that
includes velociraptors alright
so it's clear that we didn't approach
how the design of Jurassic Park in a way
to best ensure the success and safety of
the project but I also want to discuss
the breaches in ethical practice that
occurred because they're undoubtedly a
cause of the problem as well so who here
has heard of the Hippocratic oath
lots of people okay good it's a pledge
doctors give and it says to first do no
harm so who here has heard of doctors
lawyers or engineers and when I say
engineers here I mean like a structural
engineer a mechanical engineer someone
who's licensed who here has heard of
someone like that either losing their
license or being
were prosecuted for unethical behavior
that happens to the reason it happens is
that doctors and lawyers and engineers
they're accountable for their
professional behavior in order to
protect the people that they serve
certain aspects of the conception and
design of Jurassic Park and even
specifically to the software it caused a
lot of harm to the public and it should
be viewed as a failing in ethical
practice whether this means will be held
to account or not remains to be seen
Nedry is clearly guilty of unethical
behavior he introduced flaws into his
system to exploit for his own personal
gain he accepted bribes to steal
another's property he purposely wrote
code so that it would be difficult for
someone else to debug it and reboot it
and expose his malfeasance what he did
was illegal immoral unethical and
directly led to the deaths of himself
and others and I think it would be easy
to focus on Nedry and his shortcomings
because he's a contractor and he's not
part of our main org chart right and
he's also dead
but I can't let engine and its
representatives off the hook either if
we think of breaches in engineering
ethics to only include things like
sabotage and bribery we we miss the
larger picture Malcolm are infuriating
and unapologetic consultant was right we
thought about whether we could create
this Park and we never considered
whether we should malcolm was of the
opinion that the park could never be
safe and while we could debate the merit
of that position it's clear that the
potential for harm was much higher than
originally portrayed by
some of our higher-ups in the interest
of financial gain corners were cuts
which resulted in decreased safety and
that's unacceptable ethical breaches
have consequences and in our case it
resulted in a handful of deaths some
other injuries and traumas and financial
loss to a number of parties and it could
have been a lot worse I mentioned at the
start that I have an interest in
engineering ethics and this is true and
I could tell you that it comes from me
being just a really excellent person but
it's not the case if I put my business
hat on I still care about this stuff and
the reason is that I'm interested in
engineering ethics because I am
interested in resilient software systems
ethical breeches have the capacity to
compromise a system and that's precisely
what happened in this case with respect
to Nedry and with respect to engine
ethical breeches are a source of chaos
they are unexpected and their results
are unpredictable training in and the
application of engineering ethics should
never be considered what our industry
sometimes calls soft skills but rather
they should be viewed as something that
has the capacity to make or break your
system
my final pointed discussion is about
chaos engineering as we've seen engine
system experienced a high degree of
chaos in the form of unethical behavior
fragile system design and simple bad
luck the storm compounded problems for
instance if the board decides to move
forward with rebuilding and reinvesting
in the park
I believe that chaos engineering should
be employed as part of the system
but what is chaos engineering well chaos
engineering is the practice of breaking
your system on purpose observing how the
failure propagates through the system
and documenting how the team was able to
respond to the problem and then
refactoring to fix that this is
essentially what happened on Isla Nublar
but - the on purpose part so how do we
approach this first recommendation break
things on purpose but don't start with
production break a dev instance see what
happens and how your team responds
release a hypothetical Velociraptor
before you release a real one and it's
not to say that you can't move to prod
eventually but let's start with dev
second recommendation is to start small
and iterate break something small make a
prediction of what will happen see what
actually does resolve the incident and
then refactor to prevent the propagation
of the failure that was observed then
break something else and repeat train
your staff on incident response so they
aren't scrambling to figure out how to
turn on the generator or say how to
reboot the electric fence
a final point to provide perspective
another term for chaos engineering is
failure injection it might be weird to
think of something that includes the
word failure as a positive thing so if
that trips you up I would say that you
should focus on the word injection and
think of chaos engineering as a vaccine
something bad
whether it's viral proteins detter
attenuated viruses a software bug is
injected into a supposedly healthy
system the system responds addresses the
issue and then retains the ability to
address the problem when it's
encountered another time it becomes
ronger by being exposed upon reviewing
the events it became very important to
me to talk both about engineering ethics
and about chaos I really think that
these ideas reinforce each other
especially for systems that are critical
it could be argued that we have an
ethical responsibility to build
resilient systems especially when the
human cost of failure is high
additionally the ethical practice of
software engineering well it removes an
element of chaos from the system things
may still go wrong but from mistake and
not malice it's my opinion that any
further progress on Jurassic Park should
go forward with these two ideas as its
base or it shouldn't go forward at all
so how do we use these ideas to build a
better Park I want to close my talk with
the following recommendations
recommendation 1 appropriately budget
resources to software design and testing
number two increase transparency between
stakeholders no surprises 3 hire
professionals you can trust listen to
them and make sure they have the
necessary resources and hire enough
people don't discount your staff
Jurassic Park had initially been
designed to not require a lot of people
but better software or automated
software it doesn't negate your need for
well-trained capable staff number 4 to
build a better park use the principles
of chaos engineering to refine your
design well before their actual
philosoraptor running around and finally
number 5 maybe just don't as malcolm
yeah maybe just don't as malcolm puts it
this park might have been doomed from
the start
the stakes are too high and nature is
just too complex ask yourself whether
you should not just whether you can all
right so it's time to call the question
who here on the board votes to restart
and reinvest in Jurassic Park I want to
see a show of hands yeah okay and how
many want to kill the project show of
hands
okay the lights are kind of strong so I
may be wrong here but I feel like the
majority want to reinvest so so the
project is restarted and may God have
mercy all right
there is work now if you'll allow me a
minute
I'd really like to address you as myself
and not in character so thank you so
much to the Jas conf us team for having
me and my talk for this conference it
was a real pleasure my real job I don't
actually work for engine is as a
developer advocate at sneaked and it's
my job to get feedback from devs and to
learn about the challenges that they
face and to help them out so if you ever
want to talk open-source and security
please don't hesitate to drop me a line
you can see my email on the screen and
my twitter handle is there too and I'd
love to hear from you I'll also be
posting these slides at that Twitter
handle as soon as I can so you can check
that out if you're interested and I'll
probably drop a link in the slack as
well and if you're interested in
learning more about security you can
join a vendor-neutral
security education focused group that I
helped run called the secure developer
we do virtual events and we have a slack
group and there's also a podcast I think
is really good so check that out if
you're interested and I wanted to do one
more thing and because I was so excited
to give this talk and because I'm a
local and I didn't have to drag a bunch
of stuff through the airport we're gonna
do some trivia and include some prizes
for those that get the answers right so
in 1993 I was in elementary school and
we were ignored if we spoke without
raising our hands and being called on so
that's how I'm gonna operate here and
you've been warned additionally this is
1993 so you wouldn't be able to Google
stuff and you definitely wouldn't have a
phone that connects to the Internet so
play fair okay
all right so our first question is what
had dr. grant and dr. Sadler discovered
at their dig sites at the opening of the
movie enhance front table oh no that's
not it
Red Hat that is close enough
it was a Velociraptor fossil of a baby
Velociraptor come get your prize
so it's an infant Velociraptor flop
fossil all right so a retrofitted can of
shaving cream is used by Nedry Oh see I
don't pay attention when people don't
raise their hands and are called on all
right so what brand is it hands please
um let's see guy in the gray sweater in
the middle Barbasol that's right come
claim your prize yeah all right this one
I really like and I want to see hands
not yelling so which of the following is
a dinosaur let's see
let's go with the girl I think she's
wearing red did you raise your hand
tentatively yeah which one's not it
which one is a dinosaur which one do you
mean so the the one that's flying or
which one the what the flying one note
that is not a dinosaur down front here
the penguin is a dinosaur no really I
read this in a book so the pterodactyl
was a really good guess and it coexisted
with the dinosaurs but it was actually a
flying lizard whereas the general
scientific consensus right now is that
birds are not only related to dinosaurs
but they're a branch of dinosaurs and so
people will sometimes call them avian
dinosaurs and they're still here today
so that's pretty cool so come get your
prize all right yay so we have our
penguin all right and finally the
fictional island of Isla Nublar is
located off the coast of what country
[Music]
let's see Oh get in the white shirt
there Costa Rica that's right come clean
your guys alright so now it's over
thanks again to all the organizers and
especially for how inclusive and
thoughtful they were with things like
captioning and childcare I had a really
great time and I hope you did too so
thank you so much jazz comp us
[Applause]
[Music]